DAVID JORDAN: Hello,
welcome back to recitation.
The problem I'd like to work
on with you now is a long one.
So it's going to be practice
computing line integrals.
So to begin with, we have this
function of two variables.
f is x to the fifth
plus 3x y cubed.
And we have this-- C is
the upper semi-circle going
from (1, 0) to (-1, 0).
So it's this upper semi-circle
here that we often consider.
And so the first
thing that we want
to do is to just compute
the gradient, capital F,
to be the gradient
of this function f.
And then parts b
through d, we're
going to compute this line
integral of this vector field
f along this curve C.
We're going to compute it
in three different ways.
So first of all, we're going
to compute it directly,
just using the definition.
And then in Part c, we're going
to compute it using the path
independence of line
integrals and we're
going to replace the path
C with a simpler path.
And then finally
in Part d, we're
going to use the fundamental
theorem of line integrals.
Now when you do Part b,
what I want you to do
is set up the integral.
You're going to get a very
complicated integral that I
wouldn't want to try to compute.
So just set up the integral
completely and then go ahead
and move on to Part c and d.
So why don't you pause the
video and work on that,
and we'll check back
in a few minutes
and we'll solve it together.
Welcome back.
I hope you had some luck
working these problems.
So let's do the easy one
first, computing the gradient.
So for the gradient we just take
the two partial derivatives.
So we get 5 x to the
fourth plus 3 y cubed.
That's the partial derivative
in the x-direction,
and in the y-direction,
we just get 9x y squared.
So now for Part b, we're
asked to compute this integral
directly.
So we have to recall
what it means.
So first of all, if
we go back over here,
we have this curve
C. And we need
to give a
parameterization for it,
and so we're going to
introduce a parameterization
r of a variable
t, and we're going
to use that to do
our computations.
So let's set r of t-- so
this is our usual circle
that we're used to working
with, so we're just
going to take the usual
parameterization, cos t and sin
t.
And what's important is that
the range is going to be from t
equals 0 to t equals pi.
It's t equals pi
because we don't
want to go all the
way around the circle.
We just want to
go halfway around
until we get to negative 1.
So if that is r of t, then we
can compute the differential
dr of t.
And so it's going to be
just taking the derivative.
So we have negative
sin t and cos t dt.
And so now we can just write
out this line integral directly.
So the integral over
C of F dot dr just
becomes-- so we have the
integral from t equals 0 to pi.
Those are the ranges
for our curve.
And now we're going to take the
dot product of F, which was 5 x
to the fourth plus 3
y cubed, 9x y squared.
We're just going to dot this
with our dr vector, which
is minus sin t, cos t.
Altogether we have dt.
And so now, notice
that here we've
got the variables x and y, and
here we've got the variables t,
but because of our
parameterization,
we actually know
that, for instance, x
is cos t and y is sin t.
So we can write this all out.
So we have 5 cos to the
fourth t plus 3 sine cubed t.
So that's this guy
written out in terms of t.
And then we multiply it
by a negative sine t.
And then to that we add
the other component.
So we have plus a 9.
So we have cos t coming from
the x and another cos t here.
So we have cos squared t, and
we have a sine squared t dt.
OK, so that's what it
means to compute this line
integral directly,
and it's not something
that I look forward to doing.
So let's see if we can use
path independence to make
our lives a little bit simpler.
So that's going to be c.
So what we want to do is we want
to replace our original curve
C with any other curve that
has the same starting point
and the same ending point.
And the curve that
I would like to use
is just a straight
line connecting them.
There's lots of different
choices that you could do,
but to me this one
seems the most natural.
So let's give that a try.
So let's let r of t be
the curve negative t, 0.
Negative t because we want
it to run moving to the left.
And then our range is just
going to be from minus 1 to 1.
So when t is minus 1, then
we get minus the negative 1
and it starts at 1.
And when t is 1 it
goes to negative 1.
And notice that it goes
along the y equals 0 axis.
So now we can do
the same computation
that we did before but
we can use this curve.
So the thing that
I want to emphasize
is that if we're
computing a line
integral of a
gradient function--
so of a function which
is conservative--
then we can use any line
and we can use any path that
connects the two end points.
We can replace our path.
And so that's what we did.
We replaced C_1 with C_2.
So now this becomes
much easier in two ways.
So we'll see.
So our range now is just
t goes from minus 1 to 1.
And so dr here is
just minus 1, 0.
That's dr. And there's a dt.
And let's see.
So now F, we had
this value for F,
but notice that the y-coordinate
is always 0 along this curve.
So the y-coordinate
being 0 means
that we just have 5 t to
the fourth and then 0 here.
That's it, because we set
y to be 0 along this curve.
So altogether this is a
very nice integral to do.
So just taking this
dot product, all we
have is minus 5 t
to the fourth dt.
That's simplified greatly.
And we just have minus t to
the fifth from 1 to minus 1.
And so we get simply minus 2.
So that was a much, much
more straightforward integral
to do than the one
we started with.
Now finally, in
d, we're suggested
to use the fundamental
theorem of line integrals.
So let's remember
what that says.
That says that if we have any
curve and the line integral
that we're taking-- if we know
that we're taking the line
integral not of
any vector field,
but of a vector field which is
already the gradient of f, then
that tells us that
this is simply
f of the endpoint minus f of
the starting point of our curve.
So really we don't need
to do any integral at all.
And so let's see.
So recall that f was x to
the fifth plus 3x y cubed.
And so the endpoint-- so we
just need to take f of (-1, 0)
and subtract f of (1, 0).
And so plugging this all
in together we get minus 1
minus a positive 1.
Altogether we get minus 2.
And, of course, this
does agree with what
we did when we computed
using the line integrals.